The year was 2015.
Lewis, Joseph, and Sydney were like a lot
of kids their age - which is to say, eleven
years old.
They secretly stay up past their bedtime watching
scary videos on the internet when their moms
and dads think they’re sleeping.
They go to school every day, and daydream
about all the fun things they’re going to
do when that school bell finally rings at
the end of the day.
And of course, they play a lot - and we mean
A LOT - of Minecraft.
Whenever they’re not at school, hanging
out at the local park and filming goofy tiktok
videos, or watching those aforementioned scary
videos on the internet, there’s a good chance
that they’ll be online together, logging
a few extra hours building bases, digging
big holes, or playing survival mode and seeing
how long they can last against the onslaught
of mobs.
But there’s one particular pursuit they
have while playing Minecraft together that
takes up the majority of their playtime, one
Quixotic quest that drives them forward, despite
all the naysayers and doubters: Tracking down
and finding the legendary Minecraft creepypasta
entity, Herobrine.
For those who weren’t around on the internet
back then, creepypastas like Herobrine were
all the rage.
Like any video game, the new frontier of Minecraft,
with all its procedurally generated landscapes,
felt like it held new mysteries - and mysteries
are equal parts exciting and frightening.
After all, who really knows what’s going
on behind a closed door?
Herobrine was a Minecraft-specific little
urban legend.
Stories told of a default Minecraft skin with
eerily white eyes manifesting in the game,
even in solo matches, and terrorizing the
players.
One internet sleuth who looked into the mystery
of Herobrine claimed it to be the haunted
soul of the dead brother of Minecraft’s
creator, Marcus Persson, also known as Notch.
In the years since the legend first started,
Notch himself has come forward and disavowed
the claim, saying that, in fact, he didn’t
even have a brother, and never had, so the
rumors were completely baseless.
But as we here at the SCP Foundation know,
the truth has never gotten in the way of a
good story, so Lewis, Joseph, and Sydney were
happy to remain believers as long as they
could keep having fun chasing alleged digital
ghosts.
How could any of these boys known that, in
the midst of their fun, they’d run into
a real monster amidst Minecraft’s blocky
vistas?
It was a school night like any other when
they made that first fateful expedition.
It was 7:15 PM, and the boys were all in their
shared server.
Lewis had chicken tenders, Joseph had chicken
nuggets, and Sydney, who’d eaten his dinner
earlier than the others, was snacking on a
pack of Skittles.
They’d all outfitted their characters with
full diamond armor, with diamond swords to
match, because Joseph had somehow convinced
the others that diamonds were ghost-proof.
He read it on the internet, he claimed.
Together, the three boys had made themselves
an impressive Minecraft castle to be the base
of their Herobrine-hunting operations.
A safe haven, surrounded by high stone walls
and mob-repelling torches to keep them safe
if ever they got a little too spooked while
playing.
Though “playing” was perhaps too mild
a word for it.
In the minds of these three boys, they were
doing extremely important investigative work.
After all, if they managed to actually find
Herobrine themselves, they’d be creepypasta
legends.
And wouldn’t that be worth all the hours
upon hours of rigorous mining and crafting?
They’d been methodical in their search,
scoping out different corners of the map and
canvassing them together, searching high and
low and then marking said area off their checklist.
It was a level of consideration and thought
that their parents and teachers had long wished
the boys would put into their home or schoolwork,
but alas.
Seeing as none of the homework was “Find
Herobrine”, they really weren’t that interested.
Today, they were searching an area deep in
the misty forests, in the dead of night.
They fought off a few spiders and sword-wielding
skeletons - thankfully no Creepers - and kept
forging on into the darkness.
“It’s so creepy out here,” Lewis said
over his headset.
“Why did we have to come out here at night?
It’s way more dangerous with all the mobs!”
“But night is like the perfect time for
ghosts!”
Sydney retorted.
“You think a ghost is gonna start hanging
around in the middle of the day?
No way, it’s gotta be at night, man!”
And Lewis simply could not argue with such
incredibly sound logic.
They forged on, doing their typical methodical
search for any phenomena that one might generously
be able to describe as “Supernatural.”
So you can only imagine the excitement coursing
through them when Joseph discovered a strange,
dark cave that looked as though it had no
business being there.
While each held their own private reservations,
they all knew what they needed to do: Go inside
and investigate.
As they entered the cave, a few strange realizations
occurred to them - Such as the fact there
were seemingly no mobs down here.
A cave in the dead of night, surely there
should be some enemies, right?
Plus, the typical lightning implements, like
torches and lanterns, didn’t seem to offer
the same kind of illumination that they normally
would.
It was almost like the darkness was more oppressive
here, more tangible.
There was undeniably something eerie about
the whole setup, that much couldn’t be denied.
“You guys see anything?”
Lewis asked.
“No,” Joseph said, sounding oddly cautious,
as though he sensed something strange was
on the horizon.
Something that, perhaps, these boys shouldn’t
see.
“Yeah, I haven’t seen anything either,”
Sydney chimed in.
“Maybe we should--”
Joseph screamed, and the other two turned
their Minecraft avatars to look at him.
Joseph’s character had bumped into something,
some stranger in the cave.
An NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the purposefully
lofi blocky world of Minecraft.
It seemed to have a dark, furry body, with
a canid, skull-like face, bearing a pair of
milky-white eyes that seemed to stare off
into nothingness.
Was this another mob?
Maybe something added in the latest patch?
If so, why wasn’t it attacking?
“What is that thing!?”
Lewis asked over his headset.
“I don’t know,” Joseph replied.
“It’s so creepy, though.”
Suddenly, a message appeared on the screen,
as though it had been typed and sent by another
player.
A player with the username “Mal0.”
The message read, “Hey, that isn’t very
nice.
You shouldn’t judge on appearances, kid.”
That certainly gave them pause.
So many things about this didn’t make sense:
It had all the hallmarks of an NPC, but apparently
it understood their voices and could send
messages.
It clearly wasn’t actually another player
in a conventional sense, but it didn’t attack
like your typical mob.
None of the boys could really make sense of
what they were dealing with here.
“Are you a hacker?”
Sydney asked.
“No,” Mal0 typed back.
“I’m just lonely, and a long way from
home.
It’s nice to have your company down here,
though.
I don’t get visitors often.”
“Have you ever heard of Herobrine?”
Lewis asked.
Mal0 typed back, “Is he a friend of yours?
You should introduce him to me.
I love making new friends.”
The three boys were, in some regards, rather
mature and polite for their ages, and so remained
civil with this bizarre, mysterious figure.
It was curious and inquisitive, asking them
questions about their school lives and their
friends.
It did seem earnestly happy for their company,
so it didn’t give any of them the sense
that it was a threat.
As the night drew on and the boys’ respective
parents told them it was time to log off and
get some shut-eye, Mal0 finally typed, “I’ve
really enjoyed hanging out with you kids.
Come back and visit me again tomorrow.
If you don’t, I’ll come visit you instead.”
None of the kids picked up on the probably
rather obvious Stranger Danger vibes of this
message, and instead, they went to bed, excited
and curious.
The next day, they met up on the playground
for a kind of State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the night
before.
“Do you think it has anything to do with
Herobrine?”
Lewis asked.
“Forget Herobrine,” Sydney replied, eliciting
gasps from the two others.
“All the other people have Herobrine, we
have something better.
Something only we’ve discovered.
We’ve got Mal0!”
Later that night, Joseph, who was probably
the most studious of the group, tried to do
a little background research on Mal0.
Everything seemed to turn up dead ends, aside
from one slightly shady-looking app called
“MalO ver1.0.0.”
Its description read:
“Never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!”
Weird.
So unless the thing they encountered on Minecraft
was some kind of weird viral marketing campaign
for the app, it was probably just a coincidence.
Maybe it was a popular character from Japan,
or something.
Either way, for the next several days, the
boys honored their promise.
They’d visit Mal0 in the cave every night
and chat, trying to tactfully get more information
out of it.
Though the best they could get on the entity’s
origin was the cryptic statement, “I’m
not usually here, but everyone wants a vacation
once in a while, don’t they?
We can just spend our whole life on a phone.”
They’d become so acclimated to Mal0 over
the days that they forgot what the entity
had said to them the very first day they met:
“Come back and visit me again tomorrow.
If you don’t, I’ll come visit you instead.”
But on the day that they didn’t come and
visit Mal0, because Miss Grayson had set a
particularly challenging piece of English
homework, they received a frightening reminder.
That very night, they all started receiving
strange texts on their phones.
As you can probably expect, they were all
photographs, each and every one depicting
some regular haunt that the boys all liked
to frequent, with one addition - Mal0’s
grinning skull face hiding somewhere in the
image, like some kind of demented parody of
Where’s Waldo.
The strangeness of this new development left
all the boys shaken, and they hopped back
onto Minecraft as quickly as possible to go
find and talk to Mal0 in its cave.
However, this time, the cave was empty, and
Mal0 was nowhere to be seen.
But the texts still didn’t stop.
They’d come in so frequently, with Mal0
getting closer to home - literally - in each
one.
The boys thought about telling their parents,
but would their parents believe them?
They’d probably lump Mal0 in with the same
tall tales of childhood imagination as Herobrine
and write it off as bored kids playing a prank,
even though, in this case, it was anything
but.
More photos arrived.
In these ones, Mal0 was right outside each
of the children’s homes, lurking, watching.
In some of the photos, they could see themselves
in the windows, going about their evening
business, having no idea of the creature lurking
just outside.
None of the boys felt like playing Minecraft
that night.
It wasn’t fun anymore.
Instead, they shut themselves up in their
room, closed and locked the windows, and pulled
down the blinds.
After checking under the beds with flashlights,
of course.
But still, more photos came in, all depicting
Mal0 getting closer, and closer, and closer…
Right about the time they were wondering whether
the scratching on the outside of their bedroom
doors was real or just a figment of their
imagination, another dark irony had occurred
to them: All this time trying to find something
supernatural, and in the very end, something
supernatural had instead found them…
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “SCP-1471 - MalO Version
1.0.0” and “What if SCP-1471 MalO Was
Put Inside SCP-914?”
for more marvelous Mal0 madness!